[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti avete appena eseguito
il primo movimento di 433 un brano che
il compositore statunitense john cage
scrisse nel 1952 è un brano che è
composto da tre movimenti il primo di 30
secondi che avete seguito con molta
probabilità in una prima mondiale perché
il coro di duemila persone
sicuramente non l'ha mai eseguito mi
venne l'idea quando chiuso in una camera
anecoica lui cercò di trovare il
silenzio assoluto ma in quella occasione
e riuscì a percepire il rumore del
proprio cuore e il fluire del proprio
sangue e quindi capi comprese che il
silenzio assoluto è un po come lo zero
assoluto un po difficile impossibile da
raggiungere
infatti in 4 minuti e 33 sono 273
secondi come meno 273 è vicino allo zero
assoluto quindi impossibile da
raggiungere è anche il fatto che questo
brano spesso è stato pensato come fosse
dedicato al silenzio
in realtà è dedicato a un modo di
concepire il silenzio e quindi di
provarlo come abbiamo appena fatto
perché il compositore non dà nessuna
indicazione sugli esecutori che potevano
essere o appunto un coro un'orchestra un
duo un pianista ma dall'indicazione di
non cantare non suonare per tutta la
durata del brano vuole porre
l'attenzione sul silenzio come requisito
fondamentale per un ascolto sofisticato
infatti il brano è realizzato con i
rumori ei suoni dell'ambiente dove viene
eseguito c'è un un buffone dotto
rispetto a john cage la sua
partecipazione nel 1958 la trasmissione
lascia e raddoppia di mike bongiorno
lo convinsero a partecipare come esperto
di funghi ma soprattutto per racimolare
un po di soldi perché non aveva
all'epoca la fama che poi acquisì nel
tempo e stava lavorando con umberto eco
e con luciano berio e che lo convinsero
appunto a partecipare in quell'occasione
mike buongiorno spiegò la sua teoria
della musica concreta e quindi una
sinfonia per vasca da bagno frullatore
pentola erano gli anni della
sperimentazione ma soprattutto spiegò
come il silenzio era una è una
condizione del suono ed è una condizione
del suono che bisogna provare e bisogna
non farlo ma ascoltarlo
pensate un attimo a quello che noi
riusciamo alla meraviglia di immergersi
in una faggeta secolare o all'alba al
mare aspettando l'alba oppure nel
deserto dove la sabbia e il vento
formano dei suoni già noti a marco polo
come i cori del deserto tutti i luoghi
dove pensiamo di avere di trovare un
silenzio ma già all'epoca di pitagora
con la sua musica delle sfere oppure
keplero con armonie jazz mundi avevano
ipotizzato una teoria quasi metafisica
sul fatto che appunto c'era un movimento
planetario che potesse produrre dei
suoni nei luoghi dell'immaginario del
silenzio concepito non come un momento
di tranquillità ma come un faccia a
faccia con la propria ispirazione faccia
a faccia con se stessi forse anche per
liberarsi un po di quella paura che
abbiamo del silenzio che a volte ci fa
riempire di rumore la nostra vita non
calcolando che è proprio sul silenzio
sulla capacità di stare in silenzio che
si misurano le relazioni più importanti
che si misura la propria capacità di
mettersi in contatto con il non detto
oppure quel silenzio col quale ci
apprestiamo ad andare un concerto uno
spettacolo teatrale a un tè dix
è un silenzio che veicola un valore
fondamentale un po perso di questo in
questo periodo che è quello di ascoltare
per ascoltare e non per rispondere
necessariamente oppure quel momento
fantastico magico in cui io a lungo le
braccia l'orchestra smette di accordare
e c'è quel momento prima dell'attacco di
una sinfonia prima di quel momento di
congiunzione tra pubblico e orchestra in
cui si comincerà a parlare quel
linguaggio meraviglioso che è la musica
il linguaggio dell'indicibile e
dell'invisibile
[Applauso]
ascoltare e molto e molto facile
pensiamo con l'udito ma ascoltare con il
cuore con gli occhi con i gesti non è un
esercizio e io sono direttrice
d'orchestra e sono il tramite di questo
esercizio d'ascolto il tramite tra il
pubblico e l'orchestra il tramite tra la
musica è la mia orchestra e noi insieme
verso il pubblico
questo mio compito si chiama in una
parola che è un termine musicale ma che
viene usato anche nella vita di tutti i
giorni
io devo realizzare armonia per armonia
si intende fondere le diversità cercare
di comprendere da ascoltare
ognuno è naturalmente proporre la mia
divisione nell'immaginario pensiamo
anche che comandare a bacchetta
significa questo che il direttore arriva
decide dall'attacco e si fa come dico io
non è così io sono in ascolto e devo
ascoltare i singoli musicisti che
spessissimo anzi quasi sempre sono dei
professionisti di altissimo livello che
hanno una loro visione del brano hanno
un loro sentire una loro interpretazione
e sta a me ascoltarli e fonderli insieme
con la mia ma essere capaci di
condividere tutto questo si realizza con
una fiducia da parte dell'orchestra nei
miei confronti
e questa fiducia mi viene accordata nei
primi 5 10 minuti da quando salgo sul
podio in questo brevissimo lasso di
tempo
l'orchestra decide se sarò io a guidarli
se si affidano a me appunto con fiducia
ma capiranno fondamentalmente se io sono
in ascolto
se io ho questo ascolto che naturalmente
parte da una
una formazione primordiale per i nostri
per noi musicisti perché comunque è una
delle prime materie che che si studiano
al conservatorio proprio or training la
formazione dell'orecchio con un aiuto di
ascolto sofisticato ma non è solo quel
tipo di ascolto e quel tipo di fiducia
che io cerco loro sanno e devono sapere
che io mi considero un mezzo e non il
fine
questo bel viaggio da fare insieme e da
proporre al pubblico deve essere questo
innanzitutto quindi il rispetto le
pratiche collettive di coro orchestra
veicolano questo veicolano un rispetto e
veicolano l'ascolto rispetto dei tempi e
naturalmente per poter ascoltare noi
sappiamo che c'è una regola fondamentale
che abbastanza scientifica non si può
ascoltare se si parla a volte c'è una
sovrapposizione disordinata disarmonica
potremmo dire di conversazioni purtroppo
provenienti da modelli negativi che ci
vengono dai talk show televisivi e degli
scontri politici e questi modelli ci
riportiamo a casa quindi tra moglie e
marito non nelle liti di condominio
ma quanto sarebbe bello invece prendere
ad esempio un modello come modello per
la vita di tutti i giorni
una prova un concerto di un quartetto
d'archi dove come diceva al teorico
adorno l'insieme non si realizza
nell'auto affermazione imperiosa di
ognuno delle singole parti che
produrrebbe un barbarico caos ma
riflettendo su se stessi e ponendosi dei
limiti bisogna specchiarsi nell'altro
io mi specchio e so chi sono so che cosa
sto provando e so che cosa sto vivendo
semi specchio in ognuno dei miei coristi
e degli orchestrali
io vedo nei loro occhi quello che loro
stanno provando e se questa indagine
riuscissimo a farla anche nella vita di
tutti i giorni potremo capire benissimo
ascoltando non solo con con l'udito ma
anche con il cuore e con lo sguardo
quanta gioia procuriamo alla
altro ma anche quanto dolore procuriamo
all'altro e sapere ascoltare significa
liberarsi dalle diffidenze delle
discriminazioni significa provare lo
stupore per le idee degli altri avere la
curiosità di ascoltare che è quella che
ci avvicina all'arte e ad essere anche
capaci di fare un passo indietro come
quando io ho un violinista chiedo di
suonare più piano per il bene comune
e poi perché in quel momento è più
importante l'insieme e poi leggere nei
suoi occhi il godimento di capire che
quel piccolissimo farsi da parte ha
portato un risultato grandioso significa
conoscenza ascoltare significa anche
capire con quale musica ci parlano le
cose significa gentilezza e grazia delle
cose che purtroppo destiniamo soltanto a
degli oggetti in questo in questa nostra
epoca
e allora dico come sarebbe bello
trattare i nostri interlocutori come un
quadro prezioso metterlo sotto la
migliore delle luci per vedere che cosa
c'è di buono
ascoltare un talento come la felicità e
in quanto talento va allenato la mattina
ci dobbiamo svegliare dobbiamo dire che
cosa c'è di bello per me
che cosa c'è di buono e di bello da
ascoltare
non dobbiamo permettere di essere
inondati da un fiume di parole
aggressive disordinate che ogni giorno
ci riempiono la vita ma non dobbiamo
neanche aver paura delle dissonanze che
un termine musicale la dissonanza non
c'è un brano anche più recchia bile che
non contenga una dissonanza perché la
dissonanza e una momentanea è un
momentaneo allontanamento dalla
consonanza ma ha una grande attrazione è
una ricchezza e quello che fa di un
brano musicale interessante quindi
questa questo essere essere pronti ad
accettare anche l'idea diversa
pensandola che è un alimento e non un
giudizio è importante ascoltare se
stessi sapere ascoltare significa
entrare in contatto mettersi in contatto
con se stessi capire quali sono le
nostre aspirazioni e soprattutto
valutare gli strumenti con i quali
possiamo alimentare queste aspirazioni
perché le nostre aspirazioni sono
talenti che vogliono nascere che
vogliono vivere anche se ci sono stati
degli insuccessi ma soprattutto mettersi
in contatto con se stessi significa
capire quali sono le nostre sensazioni
positive catalogarle archiviarle
comprenderle memorizzarle tutto quello
che ci fa stare bene e quello parla
delle nostre qualità ma anche
memorizzare tutte le cose che ci fanno
stare male la voce rotta la paura
l'ansia e quindi fare le scelte giuste
di ascoltare per farsi ascoltare bisogna
sapere ascoltare è un atto di seduzione
quello che io faccio con l'orchestra nel
senso conduco a me non di di seduttività
ma io parlo con l'orchestra a volte un
direttore non dice neanche una parola
come ho fatto sono entrata ma comunica
con i gesti questa situzione questo
portare a sé significa avere una un
interesse di mostrare un interesse per
quello che si sta dicendo trattare
l'interlocutore con rispetto e magari
ascoltare e ascoltare in silenzio
annuendo con il capo e questo fa sì che
l'interlocutore capisce che chi ascolta
ha molto interesse su quello che sta
dicendo ma soprattutto si realizza un
atto che non dovremmo mai dimenticare
quello di essere presenti in tutte le
azioni del nostro quotidiano esserci
ascoltare senza prendere il telefonino e
dare un'occhiata e questa è una cosa
molto importante per noi
[Applauso]
la visione armonica di quello che è la
nostra vita di condivisione e quello che
può realizzare anche una condivisione di
pensieri ma la condivisione di un suono
di un inno nazionale di un coro da
stadio della nostra canzone la
condivisione di questo ci farà ci farà
essere subito complici e uniti sarebbe
molto bello se prima di un incontro di
un dibattito politico di un consiglio
comunale di una di un meeting di lavoro
ci si accordasse proprio come fanno i
musicisti si prendesse un suono e si
condividesse per realizzare quell
esperienza di comunità che il coro e
l'orchestra veicolano con me importanti
condizioni e si rileverebbe la magia di
respirare tutti allo stesso ritmo un
ritmo del tempo che è scandito dal
battito del cuore di ciascuno di noi
il mio messaggio è quando c'è qualcosa
che non capite provate ad ascoltarla
quando c'è qualcosa che non riuscite a
dire provate a cantarla no
no no no no
no
ah no
[Musica]
l'asse cinzia grazie cinzia bravissima
bravissima grazie grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie
allora io dunque noi abbiamo iniziato in
silenzio ma io ho detto sul serio che
con molta probabilità non è stata mai
eseguita quell'opera con un coro il coro
del tè dix di bologna
abbiamo iniziato in silenzio e e ora
vorrei l'armonia della piazza ma sotto
la direzione di andrea cosa devo fare io
do la nota è loro la rifaranno io
[Musica]
no
subito
armonia
bellissimo forte questa è l'armonia la
sopra
grazie grazie
grazie
[Applauso]